all right you remember my Legend of
Tarzan review when I've said that I'd
like to see a Tarzan movie that actually
shows when Tarzan and Jane meet sky into
this movie kind of so now we have it
kind of Pete's dragon so Pete's dragon
is a remake of the 1970s classic movie
Pete's dragon that you never actually
watched in its entirety and if you did
you don't actually remember it it was
just on TV when you went and visited
your grandparents for some weird reason
that's the memory I have about it anyone
and in Pete's dragon there's this little
Tarzan ish boy that is found by this
family's been in the woods for six years
now he finds a family where he had no
family before
oh yeah and his friend Eliot the Dragons
been helping him stay alive in the woods
for the past six years a shoehorn
Elliot the dragon in the summary of this
movie because I feel like this movie
shoehorned Elliot into it's what I mean
by that first of all what I liked about
the movies this movie is a heartfelt
movie about a boy finding family it has
the feels there and we stripped down to
his bones it's a movie about finding
family and or moving on it's a theme
we've seen a hundred times before in
movies and by the end of this movie this
movie does incorporate the feels for you
that said I don't really know why this
movie's called Pete's dragon because
Pete's dragon Elliot isn't really in the
movie that much now you can have a
character in a movie not have a lot of
screen time totally steal the show like
Hannibal Lecter has about 15 minutes of
screen time or something like that
totally steals Silence of the Lambs
probably not the best analogy I'm gonna
compare this movie to ET the
extra-terrestrial in both films there's
a kid and that kid has an unusual friend
whereas ET the extra-terrestrial has
that friendship from the beginning to
the end even when ETS not on-screen et's
presence is felt throughout ET is the
point of the movie in Pete's dragon we
have a little bit of Elliott the dragon
at the beginning and then there's a huge
gap where Elliott does not have screen
time I feel like Ellie got pushed to the
back of this film in an out of sight out
of mind kind of way when he's not on
screen you're not really thinking about
him you don't care about him then he
shows up in the last third of this movie
to have relevance but by then there's
not enough Pete and Elliott for you to
care about Pete and Elliott when Pete is
with the people he's clearly not with
Elliott and it concentrates a lot on
Pete with the people and not Elias to
the point is this movie is called Pete's
dragon in the end it's generic story
about Pete the kid finding a family yeah
it's been done so many different times
with so many different plot devices
usually those plot devices are in the
four
not this time I feel like I'm griping
about this movie a bit more than I
actually intended to when going into
this review but I'm just alright if you
want the summary Pete's dragon is a fine
safe time for you and your family to
have this weekend if you want to watch
this movie with your kids go for it but
I feel like a lot of you will walk out
being like yeah it had its magic
Enfield's by the end but all in all man
but really Pete's dragon at the
beginning looked like it was going to be
a really interesting take on Pete's
dragon and then it slowed down to a
crawl I really didn't care about many of
the characters I really didn't care
about what's going on weirdly enough one
of the annoyances it didn't cost the
movie for me one of the annoyances with
the fact this little girl in the movie
who's befriending Pete really doesn't
talk like a little girl she's giving
pearls of wisdom and advice but this
girl's like 10 years old she talks like
she's 23 so I just had to scratch my
head like why are you making the 10 year
old not act like a 10 year old why why
are you making her act like an adult
don't do that there are two other adults
in this movie one of them is really
irrelevant you could have had him or one
of them go over to Pete start talking
with them and then you can have a
bonding moment between the two and have
an adult actually talk like an adult not
have the kid talk like an adult isn't
annoying it's not not a big deal there's
one of the things I felt like I had to
address it in my review and in the case
I'm just gonna say Pete's dragon is
probably a better time if you're drunk
don't drink kids yeah no it's a party
alright guys so Pete's dragon have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite family movie of the
year so far whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more